our climate is changing and at an
unprecedented rate extreme weather
events are occurring more often and with
greater intensity as evolutionary
biologists we're trying to understand
how these changes in climate will affect
the biological processes that are
important for the survival of life on
our planet
here in mid-latitudes we've experienced
an increase in winter storms part of the
reason for this increase has been due to
fluctuations in the polar vortex now the
polar vortex is a constant pattern of
arctic air spiraling around our poles
but as the planet warms this pattern
becomes more wavy and sends that arctic
air farther south and as a result there
are periodic uncommonly cold winter
events at mid latitudes like this event
that occurred in January 2014 I remember
reading about the impacts that this
particular storm had on the US
especially in the southeast where
winters are typically pretty mild and as
I was reading I came across an
interesting image it's a single lizard
dead in the snow now this is an
intriguing image for me because this is
the species that I've been studying for
the past six years this is the green
anole Anolis Carolyn iNSYS so let me
take a step back and explain that I'm a
herpetologist I study reptiles and
amphibians
now as cold blooded animals or
ectotherms they lack the ability to
produce their own internal source of
body heat and because of this it makes
them a good system for understanding the
relationship between variation in the
thermal environment and aspects of form
function and survival I use phylogenetic
techniques to trace the evolutionary
history of species and climate modeling
to understand how the environment has
shifted
across that evolutionary history I then
use experimental physiology to test the
limits of organismal performance in the
face of this varying thermal regime for
the green anole i've traced its
evolutionary history to the island of
cuba which is relatively warm and
thermally stable environment all year
round but during the Pliocene a few
million years ago there was a migration
event to peninsular Florida and a
subsequent range expansion into the vast
majority of the southeastern US now as a
result of this northern migration
animals were selected in these
environments that were better able to
function in the face of colder winter
times as they moved to higher latitudes
resulting in this significant
relationship between the cold tolerance
of a population and the extreme cold
experienced during the winter time but
what happens so this is a pattern of
local adaptation shaped by natural
selection over the course of millions of
years but what happens when climate
shifts on a much shorter timeframe I was
able to get at this question using this
polar vortex so in order to understand
this I went to a single site I started
at a single site in Brownsville Texas
right near the border of Mexico now
typical winter times at this site are
relatively mild and lizards at this site
very rarely experienced temperatures
below their thermal limit but as a
result of the polar vortex there was a
shift in the thermal profile of the
winter and animals experience almost
twice as many days where they
encountered temperatures below their
thermal limit so here's what cold
tolerance looked like before the storm
hit but after the storm in the spring I
went back to this site and showed that
the survivors of this storm are able to
maintain function at significantly
colder temperatures than the population
was
for I then went back in the summer after
temperatures had returned to normal and
after there's an exigent after there had
been a next generation born at the site
this next generation had never
themselves experienced the polar vortex
but inherited inherited traits of their
parents and I found that still animals
were able to maintain function at
significantly lower temperatures this is
a signature of rapid evolutionary
response to a single extreme climatic
event within the turnover of a single
generation now it's possible that this
shift happened just by chance so I
collected more data from four more sites
moving northward up into Oklahoma and as
you move northward animals are naturally
more cold tolerant and were less
affected by this storm and I was able to
show that only in the southern part of
this transect where animals were not
very cold tolerant and hit hardest by
this storm do we see the significant
shift so why is this important when
Charles Darwin originally proposed this
idea of evolution by natural selection
proposed it as a gradual process one
whose results could only be seen over
many many generations but now with data
like this we know that given the right
circumstances we can catch natural
selection in the act and measure
evolutionary response in real time by
gathering more of these types of data we
can have a better understanding of how
life on this planet will respond to the
extreme climatic events that are
expected in the coming decades thank you